it's blac chyna like you've never seen  her before the pregnant model is most  definitely Keeping Up with the  Kardashians by leaving a little to the  imagination like hyah rocks short hair  in the eldest come spread while  flaunting her baby bump and some very  sexy lingerie she also reveals that her  first job was at McDonald's saying quote  normally you start on fries or burgers  but I was never back there I guess it  was because of my personality but soon  to be mom I've - is following in the  footsteps of her new family with a  reality TV show along with her fiancé  Rob Kardashian and while she's thrilled  about that there's one tradition the  pair has said no to their baby will not  have a K name like they're mini auntie's